MOONLIT BESHIMOV: Show of hands,
who wants to make more money?
Me, too.
Thank you.
What do you think
your financial advisor
would say if you ask him
this question and how?
Nobel Prize winning
economist Harry Markowitz
once said that he would
never be 100% invested
in stocks or bonds or cash.
If you think about it,
games are not so different.
Would you bet your
entire revenue stream
on one source of income?
A more sustainable revenue
model calls for a mindset shift.
Our industry seems
to operate in the way
that your monetization model
is determined by your genre.
Ads for hyper casual,
IAP for rest of mobile,
and subscriptions
for PC and console.
This has worked so far.
But in this talk, I'd
like to invite all of you
to challenge these
assumptions together with me.
Our economists friend Harry
said that we shouldn't put all
of our eggs in the same basket.
Can we take learning
from other genre
and rethink our
current strategy?
No rule saying that you
have to do something
just because you're
born this way, right?
In 15 minutes, you'll hear
from one of your peers' about
their innovation.
But first, let me set
the stage and talk
about monetization
diversification, the why,
the what, and the how.
Why diversify?
Our economist friend
Harry said that we
should balance our income
sources because it decreases
risk and increases revenue.
True or not true?
If you disagree, come
find me after this talk.
What you may not know is
that we also have big data
to back up this claim.
We plotted the top grossing
games on this graph
to your right.
Each dot is a game.
On the x-axis is the percentage
of the game's revenue driven
by its top 5% of buyers.
On the y-axis is the game's
turn buyer's reactivation rate.
This means that the more to the
right, the more concentrated
is your game's revenue.
This negative correlation
shows that if a game squeezes
its buyers, then they're
also less likely to come back
if they ever leave.
Therefore, we call this
philosophy $1 out of everyone
is more sustainable than
$100 out of one player.
Now, if I got you thinking about
the diversification, let's talk
about some of the
trends we've observed.
Subscriptions,
rewarded ads, and IAP--
raise your hand if you have at
least one of these implemented.
What about two of these?
All three?
Good for you.
So here's the deal.
I would not claim
that everything
I'll be sharing with you
today will be groundbreaking.
But my hope for you is
that, after this talk,
you will have learned something
new and, more importantly,
find the inspiration
from your peers' stories
to try something new and add
to your current strategy.
Now, raise your hand if you have
subscriptions in your games.
Are you thinking about it?
Raise your hand if
you thinking about it.
Awesome.
Subscriptions is not a
foreign concept in gaming.
From PC to console, many
have use subscriptions
as a content path.
However, today I
would like to talk
to you about a different
kind of subscription.
Instead of bundles,
how are mobile games
layering subscriptions
on top of IAP
to create different tiers
of premium experiences?
The momentum around
subscription has accelerated
in mobile in recent years.
On Play, we've seen a global
mobile gaming subscriptions
growth at 70% year over year.
In fact, those who
implement subscriptions
reported a boost in both
retention and revenue.
[INAUDIBLE] saw 20% more play.
And Scopely reported higher LTV
when they have subscriptions.
If those are not
enough reasons for you,
at Google I/O earlier
this year and also
this morning, we talk
about digital wellbeing.
Many top developers like
IBM are prioritizing
sustainable growth.
So I challenge you, leaders
in the mobile game industry,
to think about what
does digital wellbeing
look like as a mobile game.
With subscriptions, can we
restructure short term impulse
buys into a long term
sustainable benefits?
Maybe instead of eating all
of your Halloween candies
in one go and possibly
regret it next morning,
can't we instead have
something sweet every day
for the next few months?
Designing subscriptions requires
a mindset shift from IAP.
You may be tempted to repackage
IAP SKUs into subscription
bundles.
It works.
But there's so much
more you can do.
The keyword here is access.
The main difference between
IAP and subscription
is that, while IAP is about
ownership where the users get
to keep what they
buy, subscription's
about access, access
of different tiers
or premium
experiences and access
that you can gain and lose.
There are two new use
cases of subscriptions.
The first is aimed at
converting your buyers.
These buyers are often motivated
by a good financial deal.
Scopely subscriptions
offer exclusive rewards
that a early buyer would
want on top of IAP deal.
[INAUDIBLE] with loss protection
and higher daily caps.
This observation aims to
increase these early buyer's
time spending game to form
a habit of playing still
early in their lifecycle.
The second use case of
in-game subscriptions
is to create a loyalty program
for your high value buyers.
Much like the mileage
program by airlines,
these players are often
motivated by prestige,
rewards for the commitment
in your game, or just
to live a more
premium experience.
Ludia offers their
VIP subscribers
extra currency,
exclusive tournaments,
early access to new
content, and access--
again, the key word is access--
to a special durable that may
even strengthen with time.
Designing access is key to
meet your in-game subscription
additive to your
existing IAP economy.
If you're thinking, OK,
what about cannibalization?
Hold that thought,
and wait for Fay.
Now, raise your hand
if you have rewarded
ads implemented in your games.
Awesome.
Those with your hands raised,
you can take a nap now.
Although you may want to
stay awake for something
that may be a surprise to you.
Earlier this year, the Google
AdMob conducted the research
and uncovered a growing
segment of developers,
who were previously
IAP only, are now
rethinking their overall
monetization strategy
and, as a result, are
implementing rewarded ads.
There are three main
reasons of why you should
think about rewarded ads.
The first, [INAUDIBLE] will
entice non-payers, especially
in developing countries,
emerging markets.
These players, while they might
be more reluctant to take out
their wallet and
make purchases, they
might be more willing to
trade with their time instead.
The second benefit
is that it also
increases overall engagement
across buyers and non-buyers.
Many game developers
use rewarded ads
as a way to extend gameplay or
gift a minimal amount of IAP.
This increases time
spent for everyone,
which, in turn, increases
social liquidity, which
then enhances the experience
of everybody playing.
Now, the third reason, which
may be a surprise to you,
is that it also
predicts IAP conversion.
Kongregate found that,
across six of their games,
players who watched an ad
in their very first session
are 2.5 to 5 times more likely
to make subsequent purchases.
Of course, we can't
say that watching an ad
will cause you to spend.
But there is a clear correlation
between the group of people
who watch ads and the group of
people who are likely to make
in-app purchases.
Now, AdMob also shared
with us a framework
to help you optimize
your rewarded ads design.
Let's see what Kongregate
has to say for each of these.
For placement, rewarded ads
should be core to your gameplay
as part of the in-game economy.
The reward itself should
be useful, meaningful,
while not competing
directly with IAP.
For targeting, everybody should
have access to rewarded ads.
But the user should
initiate the experience
as to ensure to not
interrupt their gameplay.
For cadence, more isn't
necessarily better.
Kongregate found that six to
eight ads views per viewer
per day maximizes
return with the option
to watch at least
one per sessions.
For measurement, remember
to segment your core health
metrics by app
viewership and frequency.
And if you notice a
certain cohort of users
are spending less time or
money, test and iterate.
Use this framework.
Now, if you're itching to
test out rewarded ads quickly,
this morning we announced
rewarded products
that's coming soon.
Directly in your console, this
uses the same API calls as IAP.
If you're interested, talk
to your Play BD manager.
Lastly, IAP-- I will not ask for
hands as I assume most of you
have IAP implemented.
But for now, [INAUDIBLE]
why game developer who found
success previously with ads
are now also pushing for IAP.
Similar to the trend
with rewarded ads--
while IAP itself
isn't new, what is new
is the growing number of
developers, who were previously
ads only, are now adding
IAP to their existing titles
or developing new
IAP based titles
to increase their
portfolio diversity.
For example, Tapps games,
a Brazilian developer,
is known for their
hyper casual games
but decided to focus on IAP
in their Bid Wars titles.
After growing the IAP
revenue by 200% and more,
IAP is now an integral
part of the strategy.
Let's remind ourselves
the advantages of IAP.
First, it can be run and
developed by a simple team,
by a nimble team with
simple infrastructure.
We've seen teams as
small as 10 people
managing multi-million
dollar titles.
Second, instead
relying on a huge user
base or massive
installs, IAP pushes
us to think about long term,
sustainable business metrics.
And last, IAP gives you
control and flexibility
over your game and your revenue.
Now, for those of you who
are thinking about IAP,
let's quickly touch on
the design framework.
Yodo1 is the Chinese
publisher of Rodeo Stampede.
They managed to shift their
ads to IAP ratio from 30% IAP
to 60% IAP.
Let's see what they recommend.
For design, keep it
simple and flexible.
While try to monetize as many
users as possible, [INAUDIBLE]
even the user their choice of
currency such as IAP or ads.
For conversion, understand what
uniquely motivates each segment
of users will help you
create targeted offers.
And for retention,
content is king
and build a customizable
LiveOps system early, which
will save you time later on.
Now, without further
ado, I'd like
to introduce Fay, who leads
Operations from N3TWORK,
to talk to you more about
in-game subscriptions.
[APPLAUSE]
FAY GRIFFIN: Thank you, Moonlit.
Hi everyone.
I'm Fay Griffin.
I'm VP of Operations at N3TWORK.
Who are we?
We are 90 people, headquartered
in San Francisco with offices
in LA and Santiago, Chile.
We believe there are
five features that
make up a great game.
Gacha, we still have Gacha
card packs every week.
And for those of
you who don't know,
aren't familiar with Gacha card
pack sync, Pokemon or baseball
cards.
We introduce rarity in our game.
We have weekly events we run.
We have social component
in our game, guilds.
And we also have store.
Our first game out
in the market that
combines all of these features
is Legendary Game of Heroes.
An overview of legendary--
it's two years old.
We have guilds in the game.
We run weekly events.
It's primarily IAP driven.
And we have VIP subscriptions.
So today, I'm going to talk
to you about subscriptions
and why you should care.
But before I do
that, I'm just going
to give you 30 seconds
on our business model.
Most of our players don't pay.
But we have a very
small percentage
of players who do pay.
Now, we care about
all of our players
coming back every day, month
over month, year after year.
But we especially care about
that small percent who do pay.
So when we thought
about subscriptions,
we saw an opportunity
to be generous.
We'd happily give away
$100 in value every month
if we knew you were going
to show up every day,
month after month,
year after year.
And it's working.
Since we introduced
subscriptions last April,
our subscription based has
grown month over month.
So we're doing something right.
Few top lines about
our subscriptions--
in Legendary, we brand
our subscriptions as VIP.
And during this talk,
I'm going to use
those terms interchangeably,
subscriptions and VIP.
It's $29.99 a month.
Our VIP are a small but
growing portion of our revenue.
We have 30,000
active subscribers.
We have a day 425 retention
of 20% with our VIP actives.
We have a 95% log
in rate of VIPs.
And so far, cannibalization
is not a factor.
And our cost per player
is coverable by our VIPs.
Some key considerations
we thought about when
introducing web subscriptions--
we thought of subscriptions
as a loyalty program
that provide premium access.
Another thing to think about is
monthly versus yearly access.
Right now, we just have monthly.
And I'm going to tell you
a little story about why.
So one of the unique things
about our culture at N3TWORK
is that we believe great
ideas can come from anywhere.
And our subscriptions
actually came
from one of our client engineers
on legendary, [INAUDIBLE],,
he came to us and
said, hey, Google's
now offering the ability
to do subscriptions.
I think we should
put that in our game,
should be like the Amazon Prime
of subscriptions for Legendary.
So we got a great feature
from our client engineer.
But the downside was we
didn't have a 20 person design
team thinking about it.
So we didn't think of all the
ins and outs of subscriptions
when we first implemented it.
So we' got a really great
system but some constraints
in that it's not as extensible
as we would like it to be.
But we're fixing that now.
Another thing to think
about is how much
you can discount IAP for the
promise of future revenue.
The bet we made was
that subscriptions
would be highly retentive.
So we bet long term future
revenue would benefit us.
The other thing
to think about is
that subscriptions must provide
convenience to the player.
You should make it a no brainer.
A subscription player, after
having experienced playing
the game with subscriptions,
cannot imagine playing the game
ever again without
a subscription.
The other thing you
need to consider
is rewarding and celebrating
your loyal subscribers.
Celebrate, celebrate, celebrate
through VIP events, VIP offers.
Our VIPs can actually
reach us anytime
of the day to give us feedback.
Subscriber players
must feel like they
belong to a community that's
appreciated by the game devs.
And tie subscriptions to loyalty
programs whenever possible.
So some challenges--
I'm going to talk
about intuitive messaging
and stand out UX together
because they kind
of go hand-in-hand.
One thing we asked ourselves
was, how do we communicate
VIP benefits in as
clear way as possible
with as few words as possible?
One of the ways
you can do that is
by differentiating what the game
looks like for non-subscribers
versus subscribers.
One way we did this
was through color.
Our non-subscribers, a steady
state of the game is blue.
For our subscribers, it's
purple, the color of royalty.
Everywhere you
get a VIP benefit,
we theme it purple as
you can see from the mock
up on the screen.
If you turn off
the IAP, the game
looks very different for you.
It's pretty obvious.
We built it into the core loop.
If you play as a VIP, you can't
help but see the benefits.
If you turn it
off, it's obvious.
Everywhere you lost
something is super clear.
We also think of
our VIPs as they're
not only VIPs in the game
but also outside of the game.
We actually have a Slack
channel where our VIPs
can communicate with us.
Their customer service
tickets get flagged,
and they're handled separately.
Every interaction
a subscriber player
has must be a moment of
delight and reinforce
that they are a VIP.
Another thing to think about
is when to sell subscriptions.
We run weekly events.
So we might put a
pop-up in the game a day
before an event
starts to advertise
how what you get out
of a web subscription
can help you in the events.
This one I put in
here for the devs--
shared account prevention.
We needed to build
into a system a way
to prevent multiple players
who share a single Google
account from exploiting and
getting unfair advantages.
And lastly, you need to ensure
that you have high caliber
customer support and that
your customer support
team is properly equipped
to benefit your subscribers.
So IAP versus subscriptions--
many people think
of subscriptions are
just auto-renewal of IAP.
But we think of them
very differently.
To echo what Moonlit
said earlier,
subscriptions are access.
They're highly retentive
long term access to content.
IAP is content.
It's a one time situational
purchase of content.
Conceptually, we think
of them very differently.
Subscriptions help
underwrite our revenue
and improve our
pay or retention.
It also gives us a way to
personalize IAP offers based
on a player's subscription
tier rather than having
one store front for everyone.
Subscriptions can
boost IAP economy
through increased value of
products for subscribers.
And this is at no cost
to other IAP products.
So in other words, we have
seen no cannibalization.
Some things we wish
we considered--
Google's subscription
service has some really great
features--
free trials, auto-renewal
of trials and deals
so, for instance, three
months at a discounted price,
time cards, providing
an alternative IAP
to gain temporary access to
subscribing so, for example,
like a three month
Xbox Live card.
Those are all things that
are currently on our roadmap.
Now, if I'm going to leave
you with three key learnings,
one would be, given
its high retention,
VIP subscription should be the
number one thing people buy.
It should be a no
brainer to them.
The value they get out
of it is a no brainer.
Two, framing is everything.
Celebrate, celebrate,
celebrate your VIP subscribers
both inside and
outside the game.
And lastly, build fast
but maintain the ability
to iterate.
This is where we are now.
Thanks so much for your time.
And with that, I'll
give it back to Moonlit.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
Thank you, Fay.
Now let's conclude our session.
As you think about the
takeaways for this session,
I have three hopes for you.
First, I hope you
found the inspiration
to go back and reinvent
your monetization strategy.
Second, I hope that
you believe now
your past doesn't necessarily
dictate your future.
And third, I hope you
will go back to your teams
and ask them, why shouldn't
we diversify more?
With this, I'll end the session
with one question for you.
When was the last time you had a
sit down meeting with your team
to actively decide the current
status quo is also the best
strategy going forward?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]